good morning
nato defence ministers will meet today
and tomorrow
facing critical
challenges for european security and
we have heard the signs from moscow
about
readiness to continue diplomatic efforts
but so far we have not seen any
de-escalation on the ground
on the contrary it appears that russia
continues the military buildup
and we have not received any response to
our written
document or written proposals that we
sent to russia on the 26th of january
outlining the topics and items where
nato allies are ready to sit down
and
discuss with rashan to try to find a
political path forward
we will uh continue to
um convey a very clear message to russia
that
we are ready to sit down and uh
and discuss with them but at the same
time we are prepared for the worst
and if
russia once again
invades ukraine
they will pay a high price
and we will continue to expose russia's
plans and actions to make it harder for
them
conduct conduct aggressive actions
against ukraine
but
we
really hope that
russia will
engage in meaningful dialogue and
choose diplomacy instead of
confrontation and we are ready to
sit down and find a political solution